but yeah thnkx thank you so much for
coming out and and thank you for the
wonderful introduction grace and you
know big props to my employer for for
hosting us and the the earlier talks
were all fantastic I I enjoyed them a
lot so I'm sure I'm sure you all did as
well but here we are this is right once
read never hashing in the age of
analytics so this is all about charts
and storing the data behind the charts
and somehow making getting the data back
out of the storage reasonably fast so a
quick bit on who i am i am a tech lead
software engineer on the metrics team at
yelp so that's one of our infrastructure
team so it's heavy on the devil ops and
the things i went to michigan some years
ago and i have a github where all the
code for this can be found at your
leisure so anyway as you know yelps
mission connecting people with great
local businesses and I think these
statistics are from q2 2016 so it's 92
million monthly unique mobile and 108
million on the main website as you might
imagine Yelp operates at a pretty high
scale and has a lot of stuff going on as
a result we create a lot of metrics
which leads me my background you'll be
seeing the raccoon again don't worry so
what is time series data this is sort of
a broad topic and a lot of people think
it can mean different things and some
people abuse the term a little bit so
time series data is anything that you
would scatter plot histogram or monitor
in any way on our team we historically
have focused on operational metrics
things like how is a certain core on a
certain CPU and a certain server doing
is it maxed out or is it pretty idle how
many web workers do we have available in
our and one or more of our data centers
and what is the rate of HTTP four
hundred responses or your micro service
as you might imagine a lot of this stuff
is super critical to site operation the
can't just get away with having it be up
sometimes we actually need this when the
you know the proverbial brown stuff hits
the fan right for example here's one one
chart that I've actually put in slides
before just because this is a great
example of the sort of thing where your
time series data saves your bacon so
what you're looking at right now is the
logged out versus logged in times on the
Alps home page at the median on some day
this was many years ago and as you can
see something changed and the latency
and our response time went up pretty
substantially and it did so for both
types of requests what's really
interesting about this is this then take
down the site like if you were using
Yelp that day this you still used yelp
but your experience went to crap because
the page took way too long to load and
that probably didn't make you very happy
so we need to actually keep an eye on
this it's great to have it's great to
have some nagios or send two checks that
are going to page you when the site goes
down you need that but what you also
need is to notice when it gets slow or
when something more subtle happens and
we can help with that so this is
monitoring as a service is what we call
it on the metrics team and what this
means is that we support our users we
empower our developers my users are the
developers and the product managers and
the other stakeholders within Yelp so we
have to make these systems have really
great like api's client libraries
anybody can just add metrics oh I'm
writing a new micro service I want to be
able to time this critical path a little
bit okay cool do that it shouldn't be an
ordeal it should be simple and you
should just be able to do it right
that'd be great of course there's a lot
of distributed systems that back those
nice little tiny integrations so somehow
we have to also provide those at a high
SLA and we do work with some external
vendors and other stakeholders across
the company and outside on all this
stuff so that's important as well our
objective for this talk revolves around
a project that came on my plate and my
teams played about a year ago which was
to build a new
in-house metric storage system that was
how it was stated but what is my purpose
you pass butter oh my god yeah welcome
to the club we all pass butter
occasionally so today we're building a
new in-house metric system first thing
that's important is scalability we need
to keep up with the developers who
constantly want to measure more things
and we want to support them in their
endeavors what does this mean it Yelp
this means tens of millions of data
points created per minute and it also
means that you now have to put those
somewhere and keep them on hand and then
be able to get them back out in a
reasonable latency and in a reasonable
user interface this is a big part of the
user experience let's say that I can
make the perfect client library and
that's going to make you as a developer
who and we're working together it'll
make you it real easy for you to add the
metrics but if my reading the metrics
and graphing them if that stinks why
would you bother are a couple business
concerns as well like open source it
turns out if you read hacker news for
more than a month there's a new time
series database about every two or three
days and they're all different and
they're all pointing fingers at all
their friends and enemies and saying how
they are so much better than whatever
was the flavor du jour last week though
that's all no bueno so you got to pick
one and you got to pick one that is
actually reasonably cost-effective
because computers are not free yet much
to my chagrin and we have this on call
and not only am I one of the people who
are on call but also I can see several
of my co-workers in the audience and
they have to put up with systems that we
manage and so I respect them and like
them as people and I would like their
on-call shifts not to be miserable so we
need to support everything and not not
be in pain so good fast cheap pic two
is true for just about everything and so
if you read my previous slides again
what you find out is that I said I want
it good and I want it cheap that's gonna
be slow oh I can't wait both I like both
all three sounds great we have tens of
millions of data points a minute so
let's do this we pick kyros DB who here
has heard of or worked with kyros DB
okay we got we got we got some users
Tyros DB is one of the two types of
modern time series systems some of them
integrate the the storage and the thin
client together so this is like your
influx TV it's sort of all one thing
kyros DB comes from open TSD be open TSD
be used HBase well does pires thebe
they've decided they wanted to use
cassandra and this was great for us
because at yelp cassandra is a first
class citizen we have a distributed
systems team who's one of their sole
purposes what is my purpose you may
Cassandra work we have that already so
going with something that relied on
Cassandra was really really nice if
you're ever facing the same situation I
can say is if your organization's figure
out how to do it or your coworker has
the experience that is a non-trivial win
respect that and use it to your
advantage but we don't know what metrics
we need till we need them if I could
collect no metrics until the site goes
down and then say oh I bet I need these
types of metrics 31 time earn the
metrics on the site wouldn't even why
would I let the site break it just fix
the site since we can go back in time
also why am i working in tech I can go
back in time like come on so this leads
us to write once read ever most data is
an insurance policy we estimated when we
began this project a while ago that less
than 1 percent of our data that we were
collecting would ever actually be
accessed by literally anyone and we
estimated that one maybe about one
percent of that data is like always
important
these are the things that you see on you
know big screen TVs in the office any of
the remaining ninety nine percent may
become important in the future or not we
don't know I don't have a magic I don't
have a crystal ball Oracle type thing
but I do know that I have tvs that look
like that that I am managing and
required to provide systems that will
hold down that load I don't know if the
folks in the back can quite read the
captions and some of them have been
blanked out because reasons but what the
what you're looking at here is for each
Yelp web server how many requests per
second are happening right now what are
the timings on the home page at the 50th
and the 99th percentiles an average
number of busy workers and idle web
workers per server and cpu idle for
those servers so this is called the
dashboard of doom it's called the
dashboard of doom because it used to
crash a lot so we started out with an
architecture that looks like this I'm
going to try to keep the flow charts to
a minimum but like there's moving parts
I'm sorry you're getting flowcharts
that's just how it's going to be so
since the metrics come from a system we
use called fuller right which is written
go it's kind of like diamond that's out
on yelps github right now it's pretty
neat so CPU memory things like that all
comfort all right the metrics that our
developers are empowered to name
whatever they want didn't collect
however many of that they want are based
on the stats d protocol with a lot of
tweaks and shiny things that make it
really easy to use even easier and then
we also do some log processing that
turns into time series data from systems
like Kafka or scribe so pump those all
through an elastic load balancer and
have a cluster of Cairo Stevie machines
that are processing them and tune it a
little bit so that it batches things
correctly and doesn't fall over when you
go too much load and then pipe those
into a Cassandra cluster that you're
distributed systems team helped you set
up
because we have one of those which is
great and then you just then you just
take your phone in a tiny little my
sequel database to store the JSON for
the dashboards and you say read out of
this and like it's okay and this brings
me to the next question of how does this
data actually move around which is
important to the future bit of the talk
so we'll go over this quickly when you
request data from kyros DB you make an
HTTP request and you give it a start
time and an end time so maybe two hours
ago to 15 minutes ago and then you can
sit then you can include one or more
queries in that request and so a query
will have a bunch of different things
that determine the sort of data you're
going to get back so you can have a
metric name like total user time on the
cpu but then it's like we have many cpus
one so maybe a certain data center maybe
there's an attribute called Cassandra
cluster that is like this is the Kairos
Cassandra cluster and then do you want
all of that shoved into like one time
series just one line on your graph or do
you want it in like maybe a line for
every server that would be nice okay
group by hostname and then you can
aggregate that together and you can say
sum all those Pacific Coast together ten
seconds in a 10-second window you get
back a response and this is really
important because one query will yield
many time series so in this for this one
you might get back something that says
like hostname kyros one with some data
hostname kairos five with some data you
might get back a bunch more depending on
the size of your cluster and the data is
going to end up being and in Python a
list of tuples where each tuple has a
time stamp and a value and the time
stamps because Yelp elects our metrics
periodically are going to be very
commonly every 10 seconds we can have
other kinds but 10 seconds is usually
what we go with so this lee
me to cardinality and I am NOT a
mathematician and I apologize the
mathematicians in the room but we're
going to call cardinality for this talk
the minimum amount of information that
separates the individual lines on the
graph from one another the cardinality
is the things you need to know to get
that line that from that source with
that shape one time series things we
have to include are the things i showed
you before the metric name all the tags
group by hostname and whatever
aggregators you imagine you're going to
get if you say some every 10 seconds
you're going to get back a very
different shape than maximum every 10
seconds that's just going to be
completely off the hook but start and
end times do not count the TS cashed is
the raccoon of the hour and it's a web
app it's flask it's Python 27 and it
runs in docker and also in D H virtual
ends if you want and it's kind of bug
simple as far as what it is to web app
okay why a web app when you think of a
cache you don't think of a web app doing
the cash and you think you think of some
other stuff some demons going on so
kyros DB is actually mostly stateless
because it's not like in flux where it's
all combined cassandra holds the state
paris DB batches some stuff up and
shoves it into Cassandra prints repeat
but why can't this be stateless to like
why should I be thinking about making
some crazy memory map thing that will
hold all this also Paris TB is a web app
and supports HTTP though since that's
how all the traffic is going we can duck
type this death so if it walks like a
duck and quacks like a duck then it's
probably a duck right well if it
supports all the API endpoints the car
is DB supports then maybe it's Carlos DB
it's not the raccoon ashed ah you say
does this mean I don't have to make pull
requests on Griffin ax does this mean I
don't have to do front end work because
I'm an infrastructure engineer and I
shouldn't let me do that
what it means so we can reimplement all
the reed api's or that Kairos DB
supports NTS cached and we use Redis to
actually hold the cash state how many
people here have dealt with Redis okay
most of you excellent so you know it's
industry standard the API is powerful
and massive it can be really simple you
can set and get or it can get incredibly
complicated and amazon has a product
called elastic cash that basically is
push button get Redis cluster great so
now we come back to cardinality and what
do you actually put in Redis and what
you end up with is this data is pretty
complicated and if there's one thing you
take away from this talk it is that when
data is complicated and you want to cash
it you have to think about the data and
really understand it deeply first or do
anything else so you end up having two
types of data and it's the query and
then all the time series that are
returned that matched that query so
these should be saved in turetta
separately because for example I can
issue a sub-query that only give me one
time series or I can issue a big query
that will give me like 20 times series
one of those is shared so if i hash them
then there's going to be a collision if
i hash them just based on their
cardinality which is fine except not if
the data is different so we have to
actually treat them as two completely
separate query time series first-class
citizens and this will become more clear
in a minute the keys pretty
straightforward they kind of look like
that so we prefects them with K query or
mts so we know what we're looking for
and for this audience this is this is
probably probably repeat but a quick
note on terminology so hit and miss hit
rate the rate of requests sent to the
cash where the cash had data to get back
miss the right where the cash said I
don't know what you're talking about man
maybe it's somewhere else but I don't
have it and then you will hear the
phrase hot cold though hot cash has most
or all of the data that you're going to
be needing and a cold cash has little or
none of it
though hot cash has a high hit rate and
pulled cash has a very high miss rate
and then there's we're going to talk
about a warm cash it has most of the
data that you want maybe but out all of
it and we're going talk about how we
deal with such an odd scenario of what
happens when it's a hit but it's not
really a hit we'll walk through this and
we'll talk about what happens when TS
cast is really really cold let's start
here and we'll say that we have reticent
iris DB and we have our little caching
proxy here and it receives a request
from the user honest a request from the
user it's really Griffin o creating some
requests and saying I need to populate
this chart on a person's dashboard the
TS cash gets this and does consistent
hashing on the query and says okay this
is deadbeef one two three four that is
what this hash is too but i wonder if
that exists in Redis and the answer is
no it doesn't yes okay so now what do I
do well we can just send very onward the
kairos DB just proxy it through get me
that data at the response and once we
get the response we put the data in the
cache with me so far that's pretty easy
then the response back to the user
that's pretty much how colds work proxy
to kairos put in the cash now we have
hot while my co-workers told me that
this was this was a hotel she had stayed
at which I thought was amazing so in the
hot scenario we received the request
from the user we can we hash it to
deadbeef one two three four we asked
Redis about it and read it says I got it
not only do I got it but I've only had
it for like five seconds that's pretty
fresh we think to ourselves we have a 10
second cut off so that's really nice why
10 seconds well Yelp metrics are
commonly collected on 10-second interval
with some exceptions though if you have
data that is fresh as of ten seconds ago
that's a pretty strong guarantee that
you're seeing the current state of the
world
given our systems that are feeding into
this this is all configurable but we can
do a lot with it so that all looks good
and we just get the constituent time
series that go with it because we had
previously only requested the query and
the query comes back and says I have
these three time series as components
then we get those put them back together
again and we return it to the user okay
but the fine gentleman in the photo
doesn't look terribly hot he's probably
not even sweating and maybe he's warm
what happens in warm so we get deadbeef
one two three four again and we make the
hash and we ask Redis what about
deadbeef one two three four and Retta
says you know I got this but it's a
little stale in fact it's about 15
minutes stale the 15 minutes is fine if
you're running some sort of daily report
maybe but what if the site is down 15
minutes does not help you say fifteen
percent or more on your car insurance in
this case so this is the key why should
we ask for the last couple hours just
ask for the 15 minutes you already have
data in the cache up to 15 minutes ago
why would you waste cycles on your chiro
Stevie cluster wearing data that you
already have in your hand so just ask
for the last 15 minutes and from there
we merge them we actually take these
hash time series keys and the contents
that go with them and we stick Humpty
Dumpty back together again at the TS
cash layer once we've done that we
overwrite all the old data and reset
that those particular hashes in Redis
the keys remain the same the values are
now updated and they are now fresh as of
I don't know less than one second ago
and then we just return the response to
the user but I was
talking about merging and I just made it
a little text bubble and that just
sounds all very nice and cuddly and like
something that I wrote in a hackathon
and what I would tell you is that I
tried to write it in a hackathon and I
can go so well merging is actually
really hard for data like this for a
bunch of reasons because the chiro sdb
API is actually really rich it's
designed to be accessed by a front end
and not so much to be processed in
between so you have to get you have to
get creative so for example there's down
sampling so if i send a request in and
get back like two million data points
but i only have 300 pixels to plot the
chart that doesn't really help me so if
you set down sampling what will end up
happening is you'll request it over that
long period of time and it will pick out
like every you know one over n of the
total time series that way it'll match
your chart really nice and you won't
clog your bandwidth you won't waste all
that time but it turns out that makes it
much harder to merge because you're not
exactly certain what you got back in
cars DB may choose to do one thing or
may choose the other also alignment
there are a variety of features that
involve when you start aligning points
so that they all line up and different
lines on the chart will all sort of make
sense where their data points are what
happens in a third case if your cash is
actually really hot but it only has a
half hour of data in it because that's
what you've been asking for and then you
come along you say show me two hours of
data so now you have to prepend instead
of append that's another case now what
happens if it's a little stale but it
has you know it's warm and you have data
from say I don't know 15 minutes ago to
45 minutes ago and you come in and you
say I need three hours well now I need
to add at the beginning and add it at
the end there's a bunch of horrendous
edge cases to actually maintain the
cardinality around this and I won't bore
you with them but suffice it to say that
it is pretty complicated though we're
not quite done and we're going to come
back to cold
is so cold out there and the servers are
so slow I asked for three hours of data
with a certain mohel we say large query
I was going to say malicious but these
queries happen all the time at Yelp and
it's important that we support them well
yeah if you know if you understand the
system well you can you can you can try
to bring it to its knees you know just
like with any other system right so if
you ask for three hours of data with a
certain query you'll get back two
thousand time series which is a twelve
megabyte HTTP payload and it will take
approximately 20 seconds to get all that
data because these rows and Cassandra
really wide and it's running on instant
storage like spinning rust and there are
ways that you can speed it up in the
datastore but it turns out that EBS gp2
is real expensive so if we don't have to
spend that maybe we won't so how can we
beat 20 seconds how can we do that
simple you chunk it up Parros DB the web
server among other things so it has many
web workers so we can take a three hour
query split it into 6 30 minute queries
we already know how to merge them
together again we already fought that
battle and slayed that dragon and we can
do that so just merge them it's fine
that takes it down to three seconds
which is still not great but it's better
and our idea is that this cash is always
going to be constantly updating and
asking for three hours of data should be
rare so hopefully this doesn't happen
very often and when it does three
seconds beats the hell out of 20 I think
you'll agree but there's an important
note if you want to be good you have to
be good all the time if you want to be
bad you can you can go you know
volunteer volunteer somewhere today and
then stabbed a guy tomorrow but if you
want to be good you can't ever stabbed
the guy you always have to be
volunteering you always have to provide
a good level of service to your users
which leads me to read ahead and a
shadow load so if a dashboard is always
on a big screen TV at your office and it
says refresh every 30 seconds if that's
what's going on then you're always going
to be placing load on the cash and you
don't need this feature that dashboard
is always going to be quick because it's
always loading
but let's say you have a dashboard that
you look at a couple times a day or only
in times of crisis or only when your
manager taps you on the shoulder and
says hey I want to see that so in those
cases it's probably going to be cold if
you haven't looked at it for a while but
what we can do is we can run a demon in
the background or you can even do it
with a cron job and note these
dashboards are important these are their
queries and time-series and keep those
fresh keep that load going on in the
background where the users don't see it
but then if the user does come in and
load the dashboard you're thinking oh no
like now I'm going to have double the
load on kyros DB but you're not because
one of them is going to be updating the
cash another one just going to be
reading from the cash that's nice you
can also catch the catalog itself so
when I say the catalog what I mean is
occasionally people aren't using
dashboards that somebody made for them
occasionally you have to go in and make
your own charts and to do that you need
to have a drop-down menu of all the
metric names and all the tag names and
so you can cash these as well because
these can also be slow if you have I
don't even know how many metric names
like we do though these can get really
slow and you can catch them with like a
five-minute time to live and it's some
pretty straightforward it'll take a lot
of load off of the other Cassandra
tables that are not the main big one but
are the metadata performance results are
coming and I know that's why some of you
are here you want to know does this
actually work and let's talk about how
much of this you really have to put in
the cash I gave you that one percent
number and you were like that that
little actually less though one of yelps
production kyros DB Cassandra clusters
is replicated at a factor of two and
that takes 245 gigs unrep located that's
like you know 122 the maximum size that
has ever been seen in the Redis cluster
is a hundred seventy eight megabytes
representing all that data
that is zero point one four percent of
all that data that's it 99.8 six percent
of data is not requested and a
write-once read never architecture so
200 megabytes of RAM speeds up 256 gigs
of on disk storage from 20 seconds to 0
point 0 2 seconds when you get Redis
really hot but maybe it doesn't get hot
that often like maybe you're missing the
cut offs and it's just always warm and
then it's still a little slow and it is
warm a lot but most of what it asks for
is one data point at a time so it's only
cold two percent of the time you're only
getting responses in the multi second
range two percent of all the hits it
handles and if you turn on the the read
ahead in the shadow load cold is 0 point
three percent which is pretty much the
fraction of times that somebody decided
to make a new chart that nobody else had
ever made before that's what that really
is so the final architecture I showed
you this already and you know get that
into your short-term memory and then all
we do is we change it to that we just
put TS cached federated with Griffin ax
because they're always going to work
together and right alongside our little
RDS tiny little my sequel database we
can also add the Redis elastic cash
store which can also be tiny because
come on it's 168 megabytes and like you
really don't need too much for that and
if it ever goes away if you ever have a
failure in that Redis cluster blank it
out it's fine and it'll repopulate as
your dashboards reload you'll see you'll
see a couple five-second reloads and
you'll be back to business we actually
haven't encountered a failure like this
in the past mmm six months sure it's
going to happen eventually but I'm just
not that worried about it because it's
so little data to fill in and then very
you know how do you deploy this the
github project supports d.h virtual end
where you can actually make a Deb which
I believe only works on trustee at this
point but pull requests are are always
welcome there's also a docker file that
will dr. it for you and by federating it
with Griffin and this is actually
Federation is often not the right thing
to do for high-volume data driven
systems it's putting things on the same
server is just going to cause contention
right but in this case it actually works
out because there's so little data going
through this and that little bit of data
just has to be fast that honestly you
know Griffin is waiting on the system
it's waiting for its I Oh while you're
busy actually using cycles so it
actually these two play nicely together
in my opinion and of course I've learned
a couple things so for one thing
premature optimization is the root of
all evil if you go and you read my code
you will see a bunch of places and
you'll say and that looks like n squared
log N or something like that why did he
do that there's probably a better way to
do that and you're right there probably
is but when your network has 20 megabyte
payloads doesn't matter it doesn't
matter you might take another like like
10 50 milliseconds off the user isn't
going to notice in this case it actually
doesn't matter the only notable speed-up
was swapping out stock JSON because we
do a lot of serialization and
deserialization and using simple JSON
that was a nice little bump but for the
most part just worry about how you
effectively use your data resources and
worry less about the algorithms you also
have to know your user the one eighth of
a second rule after about an eighth of a
second your brain notices that the user
interface is slow in some way and so if
that only happens like Oh point one
percent of the time that sounds great
but if somebody is using your
application all the time an operations
person an SRE who's coming back
to these charts day in day out like
trying to figure out like what's going
on with whatever they're dealing with
that day that's going to happen to them
even if it's even if it's 99.9 99.99 it
is going to happen and that is why for
example the chunking on cold
optimization is really nice because it
takes the worst case and makes it you
know not so worse it is still the worst
but we have really dramatically altered
the bound and to repeat one former point
know thy data building the system isn't
really shiny it's just if it was hard it
all came before the coating the coating
is stock Python 27 and it's reasonably
well commented and the algorithms are
not particularly creative what is fun is
that you have to in order to be able to
do that bit or to use Redis in that way
you have to intimately know the data
model that you're working with you have
to know everything there is to know or
at least be willing to learn it about
the kairos DB API and about how it
respects sampling and what does it even
mean when it says a line start true and
all these details that if you were just
turning it on and just setting it up as
an operations person who is just going
to use it you don't care it just works
but you have to get into the
nitty-gritty of the data model
specifically and that is the as the main
thing also merging is still really hard
presently oh yelp has a dataset
challenge this is an academic data set
from 10 cities in four countries there
is cash money involved and it's yelp.com
/ dataset underscore challenge and
that's all I got thank you all so much
do you have any questions yes questions
heat up from a hash to a hot cash was I
remembering that right or yeah um so the
so the question was the speed up from
speed up from a pole cash Doha cash was
20 seconds down to 20 milliseconds so I
think there was a typo somewhere in the
abstract it'll turn 20 seconds into 200
milliseconds very easily and you end up
paying a lot of that just on the size of
the payload you're handing off and
actually my real question is what is it
what's the latency for a warm cash the
latency for a warm cash on one of these
will just say all of these it's probably
arrange this crazy yeah you're looking
you're looking in the order of somewhere
between maybe 150 and 500 user observed
milliseconds like at the browser so that
includes network in terms of actually
doing the processing it's pretty light
and this is even with like some N
squared things happening it works thanks
Oh how far back do keeps a Tekkit
10-second granularity data and what do
you do with it when it stalled so the
question was how far back do you keep
the 10-second granularity data and then
what do you do with it so we actually
run two different metric systems and
this is just one of them another one's
run through an external vendor the
external vendor as the data ages out it
gets rolled up into a lower and lower
granularity until it's eventually TTL
doubt entirely in this system and kyros
DB by the way they just added this
feature they do support roll ups now
which is neat but in this system after
after after some number of hours it's
TTL doubt entirely just thrown out this
is intended to act as a as an insurance
policy much like data as an insurance
policy the system is a bit of an
insurance policy if you have downtime
from your external vendor and your site
goes down you still need something
though how far back oh how many hours do
keep
um several three right now I believe
anybody else yes sorry you didn't
mention how much time you spend in the
merge be merged with streams and like
how complex is the merge is it just a
pre-planned append or you actually
physically milch every time so the
question was how much time do you
actually spend in the merge is it just
prepend append and and how bettin
essentially how bad is it so there are
actually two merged strategies that are
implemented and it uses a couple
heuristics to choose which one it should
pick one of the merged strategies is
just a straight is just a straight app
end but you have to be careful with that
one because if the data's of different
granularities this can get messed up or
alternatively sometimes they'll overlap
a little bit like this and you'll have a
couple that are out of order and then
things get real weird so in the in the
display so it checks a couple of them
and then checks for the expected
granularity that it is expecting and it
will use the very fast merge that just
that just essentially sticks them
together if that's okay and otherwise it
will actually go oh of n down them both
how do you determine the cluster size to
split up the large data sets um the
cluster size to split up are you talking
about the closer size of split split up
send the light when you go and fetch a
big file off of Amazon how do you
determine how to split it up into
smaller files fetching a large file are
you talking about are you talking about
piracy be payload or I'm not sure what
you mean by sketching a large file oh
the chunking the chunking solution um so
for the chunking solution we came up
with half hour chunks um based on both
the size of the queries that users were
commonly making which tended to be in
increments of an hour or and also based
on what our install of Kairos DB could
easily handle
we could push it out to there was a sort
of a nonlinear performance loss by
chunking it at one hour also chunking at
at 15 minutes ends up just being too
much parallelism so that affects the
number of web workers the car sEBI has
so just with the configuration that we
had that worked really great for
everything else because you still have
to maintain like perfect ingest on this
system so you're balancing you know I
don't know if anybody else has heard
this but like the joke about cassandra
is yeah you can get data in but can you
get it back out though we had to we had
to balance this and we couldn't really
change too much because we had gotten
kairos DB to actually handle the volume
of data on a very small number of nodes
that we could actually handle so I'm
interested in kind of the thought
process of choosing cops TV again um so
I guess simply in addition to the
pre-processing that it does for you what
is another big pain point i'm using
Cousy be another big pain point another
negative another big negative of using
cars DB is yeah it's it's configuration
can be challenging and there are certain
like sort of small rough edges around
the API like for example there's a big
long list of not supporting characters
that is not immediately obvious until
you've until you found the JVM I think
that has been fixed in a recent version
but you know it's teething issues mostly
tires DB is mostly a complete rewrite of
open TSD base so they while they had a
lot of experience in the like a lot of
like experience already acquired from
that process they also had to read it a
lot of it and so their their their
challenges with configuring it to
configuring it to do
want to do also there's a big problem
that is about to be fixed because I'm on
the mailing list so I keep track of this
stuff and it currently uses it only
supports the thrift the Hector thrift
interface for Cassandra which is super
deprecated and c ql is so much better
like the datastax drivers and so that's
they're working on integrating that now
but at the moment it means that you have
to be very careful with the things that
you do to like you know auto fill out
nodes if they go down or if there's a
network lip things can get very
interesting in that so I'm sure that's
going to be fixed in so I notice you
still have a pretty big percentage of
the warm or cash it I you guys keep talk
a little bit if you guys addressing it
to increase the hard cash hit or whether
if just good and good enough currently
so that's a great question basically
warm is the the percentage of warm hits
is much larger than the percentage of
hot hits and how do you address that so
the easy way to address it is to change
the ten-second good enough value so if
you bump that up to 30 then everything
within that 30 is going to be hot and
and theoretically the and actually I've
observed this the ratios will change as
you'd expect mostly right now it's good
enough because warm is maybe on average
only twice as slow as hot so the
performance degradation and it's still
fast enough that the dashboards like to
the user feel fast per user facing stuff
this is how I've always measured it it's
like it's it's really cool to actually
take down the data but if I reload it
and I feel that it's fast and then I
asked several my colleagues like hey is
this fast to you like their reaction was
this is so much faster than what our
vendor gives us so large large there's
definitely large dose of good enough
this is a question regarding the hot
cash um I'm sorry the cold cash the one
we actually retrieved from kairos TV and
then right redis so I'm Kyra iris is
that the name again okay so that is um I
think you mentioned that it's
potentially just like an HTTP service
right there like provides an HTTP API so
there are reason why tsk she has to like
right to read us instead of like making
Kyle's to be directly write Reuters and
proxy the response back to your caching
layer like then i guess like its proxy
it back to the dashboard yes there there
is a very good reason and if and if you
think it's a bad one that is totally
fair the reason the reason that this was
not I did not want to modify kyros DB I
wanted to use it exactly stock I did not
want to modify Griffin ax I wanted to
use Griffin exactly stock and I
certainly did not want to touch Redis so
I just wanted to be able to do it all in
like a drop in component without having
to go and I'm pretty certain that this
would be relatively easy to implement in
Redis Redis like support in kairos DB
but it sort of degrades the separation
of concerns right because the whole
point of kairos DB is it will ingest
your data super fast and it will give
you some some querying tools and some
ability around that and for certain use
cases like for example a lot of
scientific labs are using tyros DB to
handle experimental data from like
real-time sensors and so on and so their
needs are commonly not dashboards it's a
lot of reporting and a lot of graph
generating it's offline work and so for
them like having a Redis cash just seems
like more operational overhead whereas
to me it seems like you know very
essential and it just didn't seem it
didn't seem worth dealing with okay so
the next question would be I'm regarding
the yes the two solutions that you're
using right one is external vendor and
one is like something that was homegrown
and you kind of mentioned that this
would work as a fallback if in case
external vendor goes down so on I was
just wondering and but they also be did
mention that this actually outperforms
extra minor in terms of just like the
speed of floating so on so I was just
kind of like
during their you you kind of like draw
the line there's like are there any
future plans gonna like just keep this
completely in-house or like this tool um
do you see do you still see in a utility
in kind of like just farming this out to
someone else as well um the the question
revolved around the difference between
using a vendor and using and homegrown
solution and wear this wear this is
faster on Reed's than then then the
vendor and the answer is as some things
about that some things about this are
tricky because it is it is very valid
who have a have a partner not just the
vendor but a partner who will listen to
your future requests and who will
support you in doing the things that you
want to do and getting the bells and the
whistles that that contract suggest you
should whereas with this the metrics
team is focused on providing a great
product to our customers and part of
that is sort of making the appropriate
trade-offs I don't want to send a bunch
of infrastructure engineers down a
rabbit hole of making brief ana's
interface makes sense that is a
challenging thing and and something that
something that a doesn't sound fun and
be just is not in our bailiwick whereas
if we work with a vendor who actually
have a great user interface then they
have people who care about those things
you mentioned
the time series databases what was some
of your technology down selects like
where the other time series databases
you're looking at and why not influx
them so what what were the time series
the demica cut at the time when we were
doing this there were a handful that
we're considered we considered influx DB
pretty thoroughly but at the time they
were limited to only scaling out to
three nodes of storage which is just I
not that's not okay they they have now
released an enterprise version that
surprise you have to pay for which also
doesn't leave a great taste so also even
at three nodes kyros and Cassandra
outperformed it by a factor of three in
my in my back-of-the-envelope my
co-workers back-of-the-envelope stress
tests especially on ingestion we could
we could do at least three orders of
magnitude more the way we had set up
piracy beyond equivalent hardware
prometheus at the time was not merely
mature enough to handle the the sort of
user support that we wanted to provide
there were a couple others like we
didn't use open TSD be because yelp
doesn't really do HBase we do Cassandra
instead and I don't want to be the first
person who's trying to support HBase
well I think that's all for the
questions you guys have such a good
audience today thank you so much thank
you so much for coming and